grab a wire coat hanger and about five
feet of string tie the Hanger's hook in
the middle of the string wrap the ends
of the string around your fingers and
then stick your fingers in your ears
now let the hanger dangle as far down as
you want and with your ears firmly
plugged swing The Hanger into something
solid like a wall or a table or a chair
leg
okay now to you those collisions
probably sound pretty weak
but to me oh well every time the hanger
vibrates it sends vibrations through the
string to my fingers and then into my
skull that causes my eardrums to vibrate
in a very special way so that what I
hear is a deep beefy gong sound
try it yourself